rawrr Commons is really the first of its
kind dining program for CMU one of the
things that we are focusing on as a
program and bringing to our university
is offering healthful foods providing
that choice but also looking at food
more holistically fueling our bodies
with real foods as opposed to foods that
are highly processed or contain a lot of
artificial ingredients we have a deli
concept where the bread is baked
in-house the meats are roasted in-house
you can customize or choose from a
signature sandwich and really make it
your own I really love our 100% organic
salad bar it's so full of all these
fantastic fresh fruits and vegetables
nuts seeds lots of plant protein so you
can really build something that is
custom to you and has all this really
great nutrition there grab-and-go
program here is really unique as well
and they have a raw foods program so a
raw vegan offering that they would have
in that grab-and-go cooler that you
could also purchase as part of a block
meal Rohr Commons also features tags
odorous second location on campus they
do a sustainable coffee program an
espresso program in partnership with
counter culture coffee and they have a
very strong emphasis on local purchasing
for all of their ingredients from the
milk that they use for their espresso
bar to all the ingredients that are in
their grab-and-go food program